from the headquarters in Derby is the
chief executive of rolls-royce Warren
East Warren thanks very much for joining
me I understand you can't be specific on
where the jobs are going to go right now
but presumably a lot of them are going
to be here in the UK unfortunately yes
there will be a number in the UK of our
civil aerospace business approximately
2/3 of the job the existing jobs are in
the UK here in Derby this is this is the
centre of our operations and and and
therefore you know there will be a
significant number in in the UK is it
possible that some sites may close
outright it is possible we are going to
carry out a thorough review of over all
of our sites I mean we can't just scale
down each one of our sites in proportion
to the total number of job losses we
would then end up with with own economic
sites and so we have to go through it on
a site by site basis consultation with
with employee representatives and unions
as well that is going to take some time
the union's have been quite critical of
this decision they say that you
shouldn't be doing this while you're
taking public money yeah the money as in
the money that we are taking from the
government for furlough schemes and we
have nearly 4,000 people in the UK on
furlough at the moment is is very
welcome support from government to help
us through the short term crisis these
job losses however are about the
medium-term
impact of that crisis on the global
commercial aviation sector as a whole
and and you know unfortunately what
we're looking at there is a reduction in
demand and we have to make sure that our
capacity matches that demand
you've said that demand is obviously you
don't think it's going to return for
several years to pre-crisis levels have
you actually been suffering from order
cancellations already in the crisis yeah
we have already seen deferrals and
cancellations and a few weeks ago we saw
the major air framers
pushing out orders and therefore
reducing their rate of build of engines
by by 40% or so those announcements
happened during April but of course
don't forget our businesses is also
quite significantly about servicing the
engines of our existing fleet that that
airlines are using and if airlines have
fewer passengers getting onto planes
then they require fewer engine services
so so it isn't just about reduction in
demand for new engines and crucially all
the job losses are going to be in the
aviation part of the business defense
which is based in Bristol is not going
to suffer any headcount reductions
that's true I mean the one sticking to
the positives for a moment half of our
business is not civil aerospace and you
know our defense business so we've said
is largely unscathed through this crisis
few small supply chain issues just
during the crisis but the business is
performing robustly and the outlook is
stable going forward so we don't see any
need for job losses in our defense
business has it been any moment during
the last few weeks Warren where you've
thought that this pandemic might
actually be an existential crisis for
Rolls Royce it's certainly a very very
serious impact and you know our job is
to make sure that it's not an
existential crisis for Rolls Royce it is
having a serious impact on half of our
business but you know we believe flying
Aviation is a good thing for economies
it's a good thing for society and we
believe that it will come back it's just
not going to come back to the sort of
level that we saw it in 2019 for quite a
few years and because we do believe it's
a good business in in future and we
believe we have some great opportunities
as we we help our customers get to
ultimately zero carbon flying then you
know we need to preserve our business
preserve the vital skills we've got here
in the UK here here in in Derby to make
sure that you know we do have a future
for our business going forward into that
into that great opportunity now if
you're suffering all of your competitors
will be suffering is there an industrial
logic or rationale behind consolidation
in the sector now yeah I think the
sector is is actually very consolidated
we are just one of a very very small
handful of companies around the world
who can do this I think it's an
important asset for for the UK and we're
going to work hard to protect that asset
and leaving aside for a moment the
pandemic are you still grappling with
the issues with the Trent 1000 engine
turbines how closer I to resolving that
well actually you know on the subject of
silver linings then we've made good
progress over over the course of this
pandemic with with Trent 1000 and we're
absolutely on track to be single-digit
aircraft on ground by by the middle of
the year it's just such a shame that our
airline partners can't actually fly
those aeroplanes at the moment because
because they haven't got any passengers